well hey everyone I have a special guest
who's gonna be basically interviewing me
today
he contacted and thought it'd be a great
idea to do a video on what kind of food
I ate in college
and also recently before I got an Aikido
you know Ben Kido for about at least two
months now so I've been doing good now
I'm just I'm being sarcastic but anyway
a lot of you guys know Logan's need he's
here lie and he's recording me and I'm
recording him so how you doing Logan how
are you I'm doing really good question
I'll tell you is like hey you know why
why didn't you change it was eating and
so I'm really glad to kind of answer
that for people like what did you eat
you know you know it's like to be
questioned well though I think that was
the number one drive to get me an Aikido
because it was so bad I mean I'm talking
that like slightly bad it was extremely
bad I was like the epitome of junk food
junkie on steroids so do you want it do
you want to join me just gonna go
through a few things to show you
okay all right so I just have to find my
screen can you see my screen okay so I
consumed now this is like in college
like I mean I ate poorly my entire life
but I really did bad in college so first
my main food was prego and
[Music]
pasta so let's see if I can switch his
pasta you've seen that before right and
so did this spaghetti thing it was cheap
I mean you know what was interesting is
like there's a half a cup of prego is 10
grams of sugar so it's just just a lot
of sugar on pasta a lot of carbs so I
was just carbon out I was doing the a
cheat meal on a daily basis it was I
guess a high carb diet yeah and of
course we
deep fry night each week at our house
and we had a house of college students
it was terrible we use Crisco
now Crisco is trans fats yes well now it
says no trans fats but it was back then
it was trans fats it was like
hydrogenated oil and then we would
deep-fry things but what I didn't know
at the time is that you had to set when
you deep fry you have to set the
temperature at a very hot temperature I
didn't know that no one told me that so
we end up cooking deep fried foods in a
broiler that wasn't very hot so if you
actually try it just makes it really
soggy we would deep-fried everything
okay and then we would eat this crap and
I was wondering why I broke out with
such a bad acne it was just terrible
like I started getting terrible acne so
we had the deep fried night and then
what else did we do Hormel chili was
really cheap so there was a store that
this kind of store that you so all this
canned meats and I did a lot of Hormel
chili and of course I poured it on chips
right with some tacos after some
basketball practice tacos with beans and
all that sort of stuff beans and beef oh
man I mean it's like this curious like I
mean there's no shelf life at this I
mean you know the last 20 years I'm just
wondering what kind of what it does to
you in long-term I used to crave salty
things so Doritos is what was my go-to
thing so I would buy the mega packs I'm
talking like like huge bags
I would down the entire bag in one
sitting no lie that's a lot of sodium
yeah it's a lot of msg a lot of my
fingers would just swell up like I had I
was clueless with my nutrition I was
completely and utterly clueless I think
because I didn't have any physical
problems
I was I was thin that was like wow I'm
skinny I'm healthy you know I can eat
what I want that was my mentality yeah
and of course don't forget the massive
amount of Cuban coffee not some diluted
stuff like Cuban coffee is very very
thick I would drink Cuban coffee not by
the shots I would drink like large
glasses of Cuban coffee
I'm talking like all day long until like
late at night like I would study until
12:00 it was weird because when you went
to went to Chiropractic College you have
like you actually have bells every hour
and you take are things like five or six
classes and you're going and then every
class you have to study for at least an
hour get home 5:00 5:30 and then study
in till midnight and I had to stay awake
so I started making mass amounts of
coffee and at first it was like great
you know for a couple weeks and then I
started actually getting dizzy and renal
stress and of course yeah - two whoppers
at that time it was like I think it was
like two bucks for two whoppers it was a
dollar a piece now it's six dollars
that's expensive jeez
back then it was like a buck for a
whopper and I would do this like on a
regular basis it was cheap right but of
course I got my vegetables right your
groceries I'm like yeah you're exactly
right but I'd rather spend the money on
the groceries than the medical bill but
that's what we have insurance for that's
why we pay three hundred thousand three
thousand dollars a month on health
insurance to pay for a medical bills I
would I remember just downing like a
whole huge French bread loaf of bread
like and I remember taking a caps and
we're just eating the entire loaf of
bread without even like thinking twice
so that just went on and on until I
started consuming these right here
because I started getting heartburn
I remember my muscles release in
Bazin all the time i went home one time
and I just shut the door behind me
my entire back froze up in a spasm and
it was in the wintertime and so I
literally went outside and I laid in the
snow I didn't know what was wrong
well it wasn't my back it was actually
the gallbladder well it was so in spasm
that it created pain into my back and
that went on for like 12 years so I did
not have a clue now you can imagine this
is why I am so driven to steady health
because I was so sick yeah so then I
wanted to get healthy so of course the
next best thing that's become a
vegetarian yeah so I started doing beans
and lots of carrot juice lots of salad
and I didn't do any any animal protein
this lasted I think probably two months
it was I was I was so gassed out like my
abdomen was like bloated all the time I
was trying to try and get healthy you
know trying to get healthy and so then
we at this time I graduated and the
whole thing and then I met my wife in
San Diego and we would hang out in
Pacific Beach and then there was this
muffin place and we would just down
these like massive muffins for breakfast
yeah and of course I would do life
cereal for breakfast at this I would
have muffin tonight you know blueberries
it had brand it was healthy whole whole
healthy grains oh yeah yeah protein and
I need the protein
muffins oh yeah totally black seeds and
then and then we went to a lot of a lot
of pizza I just a ton of like dough and
it just sat in my gut and so I was like
I started getting really really sick
right and then let me see how I go back
to okay right here so then I go back to
trying to trying to get help because I
started getting tired
I started getting weak I started I
actually turned like slightly green I
was just like really sick I had
arthritis and stuff so I would be
driving down the street and I would see
this building and said hey that health
house I said honey let's go over there
and check it out maybe they can help me
we go in there take all these vitamins
out and start taking vitamins and then
just start taking vitamins that was my
solution and then there was a whole year
where I did a lot of ice cream to help
me sleep at night because it helped put
me in a sugar coma and just go right out
I mean this kid went on for so many
years until I think it was like 28 which
was actually about two years ago and
then I'm just kidding I basically yeah
right I'm 32 now I'm actually 53 so then
what happened was I read this book
called mastering the zone hmm and it
mentioned something about insulin and I
was like what he said something like
eating a eat a protein breakfast you end
with a buffalo burger and I ate it I was
like what oh my gosh do I feel better I
could find like my vision was better
like someone took a helmet off my head I
had severe hypoglycemia at the time so I
was like wow this is amazing so I
started to jump into that for a while
and at the time in San Diego Weston
Price was was pretty popular and even
the the the I went to the organization
where they had it right in San Diego and
I hooked up with them and Bernard Jensen
I got in colon cleansing and the whole
thing and started doing all sorts of
experiments and things like that with my
diet and that just went on and on and on
and on and all right not a problem
because everything we have is recorded
and I'll send you the file yeah so
pictures of both you and me and then at
that point you know things just kind of
went on and I kept refining things and
started doing D toxins and my version of
a like a fast now this is this was a big
mistake so I try to do fasting right
without working up to it
like here I had blood sugar issues and
I'm going to jump into fasting like
overnight and try to fast for a whole
week like literally I was so weak and so
in pain starving and hungry that I don't
even know how I survived and this is an
example like you should always go in the
fasting honest gradient approach like go
into it slowly work up to it so you can
switch you body over the faculty I
didn't know that you had to do that so I
that's why I was so much against fasting
like that's just like painful for a week
not eating so I did it wrong and then so
at that time we kept trying this and
trying that and eventually to make a
long story short I started to kind of do
keto without really really knowing was
keto but with but it really wasn't pure
because I was doing snacks in between
and I was doing apples okay okay apples
like I had a lot of apples in between
the meals so it's kind of like key to
with apples right it was my so you can't
do keto like halfway like that because
it you know you'll never get into the
fat burning so I didn't know that and so
I'm gonna show you something okay just
stay right here see if I can show you
this right here let's here look look at
around my head is 211 a solid muscle
not just good I just had a I just had a
like my face is literally getting round
I'm like what the heck is going on I'm
eating
that was my son got married and so I was
like I had a you know and I just had
this little kind of pizza crust going on
and I'm like why what's going on I'm
eating healthy I didn't know so so now
that you're more lean and like you've
seen those results I'm sure you
obviously play a better energy but you
just like do you feel the inflammation
is like just gone I had I had bad
arthritis and so all that inflammation
that I had is like completely cleared up
and it just blows my mind because I
thought that it was more permanent I
didn't know it was related to insulin at
the time so I had a lot of aches and
pains and old injuries that were just
haunting me but now it's like barely
there and the times that I do longer
fasting it's like it really just goes
away so you know it's a 180 now and I
don't want to lose any more weight so
I'm doing I have a personal trainer and
I'm just hitting it hard every other day
and but I'm because of my old injuries
especially to this shoulder you know
it's it's taking a long long time to
recover because I broke this elbow and
this shoulder two separate incidents
like 3030 C screws and the elbow screws
into the shoulder so the dynamics of the
flexion extension on that side is kind
of messed up so it's so that that's what
happened to me but so what happened is I
cut out the apples and I cut out the
snacking like BAM just dropped right
down to very very fast and I was like
you mean to tell me a simple fruit was
throwing me off and so when some people
say oh yeah I can't believe we're again
screwed its fruit spine this fructose is
handled differently in the body and so
that fruit is like that could be enough
to bump you out of that burning for a
long time
I personally
you know patience work with them and I
started cutting everyone just getting
rid of fruit I mean here it was my
original book recommended apples and
fruit unlimited apples it was so bad
and so I basically had to clean all that
up you know I had to tell people you
know what that was a mistake I'm sorry
about that cut out the apples and then
people started losing weight like crazy
I'm like okay so I'm very open to if
something works you know I'm just gonna
I'm I'm gonna change I don't have this
mission to be right about anything I
just want to be successful so I'm very
flexible at trying different things and
something works that is killer so guys
with that being said that was dr. Berg's
diet before quirky know what he was
doing you know a lot of people might be
doing what he's doing right now if you
are I hope you're understanding what
transitioning to keto and an overall
healthy lifestyle can do for you if you
make that change so Wow dr. Burke thank
you so much yeah and I'm glad that you
also like the lighting in this room it's
like the worst lighting planet so I hope
you can see something but we just want
to reduce quick video guys thanks for
watching and thanks and we will we'll
touch base real real soon thank you
you're welcome see ya